how do you reject nation Greg Alva here
I'm John so we are gonna do a spoiler
talk of Black Panther I haven't heard
anyone spoiler talk of this movie so I
don't know what the main things are that
people are touching on I'm just gonna
keep it to whatever really stood out to
us what we really feel like touching on
why beat around the bush anymore it's
probably a little bit of a talk so let's
get into it right now yeah when T'Challa
and kill monger connect over their moms
names it says really I've actually seen
this movie twice and the opening of this
film he didn't donal me the second time
I watched it that there's this narration
going on where a man is talking to his
son is giving the whole history of
Wakanda it kind of just happens suddenly
in the film like if there's no Marvel
logo or anything
all the times I watch it I was like oh
sorry it's just right into it I really
appreciated the structure of this film
the second time I watched this movie
even more because it dawned on me like
oh that's sterling K Brown and he's
talking to little Eric hill maunder at
that time in that scene I thought was
way more brilliant the second time I
watched it because I really got the
mislead of it and the set up it's easy
to miss cuz the first time you watch
that scene when to Chaka is talking with
his brother you find out to chacas
brother is what allowed Klaw to enter
into a con and still vibranium 30 years
before the present time in which this
movie takes place it seems like it's
primarily a setup for cloths that way
they're building up the villain of the
movie and they're building up Klaw I
remember the first time watch it that's
what I thought they were doing okay cool
they're setting up whoo Chloe's and his
whole backstory and like oh wow he's the
villain that we got to take down but
really what it's doing is setting up the
intensity and the personal experience of
what kill monger is gonna be going
through it's kind of killing two birds
with one stone and such a brilliant
scripted format because when you first
watch it you think it's all about Claude
when really the second thing you watch
you're going oh this is this is all for
Eric kill mom well yeah you're gonna get
a dual origin going on in this movie
with both T'Challa and kill monger
because yeah you start on kill mongers
story and the crux of what's to come
yeah and the sins of the fathers before
us and all that stuff one of the
concerns I had about this movie before
watching it
the only concern I really had was how
are they gonna balance having two main
Black Panther villains in one film claw
and kill monger I think the structure of
this film is brilliant because the first
half of this film you get a little bit
of kill monger you don't really see much
of him it's weird because Gump before
going into this year a lot about Michael
B Jordan and then the first like our our
ten you don't really see the guy you're
like I'm just gonna shove him into this
movie at the end this fell yeah really
they're really taking their time with
other stuff yeah yeah I thought that was
a cool switcheroo to kind of build up
claw and then pass that torch after a
certain point yes when claw serves his
part of the plan then we switch over to
kill monger fully and it was cool
because Andy Serkis hasn't appeared in a
film of the MCU since age of Ultron
where a claw was initially introduced
sending a black panther way back when I
think what is kind of a bummer is that
he does get killed which is exact it's
great effect for the plot but it's
really more I'm just sad for Andy Serkis
because he's so great in that yeah he is
having so much fun in a way that is also
completely fun to watch he's a terrific
villain in and of himself so you think
you're watching this crazy kooky villain
and then yeah when they actually killed
him that took me by surprise and in a
Marvel movie it was nice to be reminded
of those stakes to miss a character I
loved watching I think that death scene
is really good because of the switcheroo
because the first half you're kind of
just seeing kill monger as sort of
clause number two his main henchman guy
but in that scene kill monger turns on
them kills the people it immediately has
effect where you see how ruthless kill
mongers willing to be when he kills his
own girlfriend like oh this guy's evil
nothing man I get why yeah just the
beauty of it kill mongers whole journey
is great I think it's so awesome how you
don't really see much of him or hear
about him but they're setting up to
reveal him like and do this huge
unveiling about him because what makes
his character so effective here is that
you actually sympathize for him yeah and
beyond the audience sympathizing for him
to chala sympathizes for him and that's
a big part of why I think we care about
this guy because when you're watching
the film when he's being ruthless
you still get where he's coming from you
still get why he views things the way is
cuz this guy's been robbed
yeah you get the tragic misfortune of it
all you can see how this could have
ended up so much better but because of
these little lies and deceptions it's so
much worse and what's cool is when he
comes into Wakanda I love that for most
of this movie when you're watching like
the African American actors or African
actors not sure which ones were African
American it's probably a combination
right they have a very specific way of
handling their dialogue it's more in
tune with like actual African culture
but when kill monger shows up he's got
the street talk yeah he's dad the whole
time he's in Wakanda there is like an
odd fish out of water 'no Seban he just
walks in like he owns the place i
actually saw this a second time my
girlfriend and she brought up some
points to me that never occurred to me i
thought there's some pretty valid point
kill monger shows up and he's talking
about how he wants the throne and he's
challenging to chala for the throne
there's two things that didn't get
brought up one i can see an argument for
of why it wasn't brought up but there is
another one where i'm like this
definitely should have been brought up
the first argument that that she brought
up for us was how come no one mentioned
that kill mongers father betrayed
Wakanda and is the reason Klaw was able
to get in to Wakanda because Daniel
Kahlua is whole motivation in this
entire film is he just wants Klaw to be
captured he wants Klaw dead and that's
why when kill monitor brings him by he
immediately switches his whole mentality
towards all of how Wakanda should be run
because this guy brought Klaw in no one
bothers to bring up I mean sure only
Zuri and T'Challa know T'Challa could
have brought it up although there's this
whole political thing and it causes
mistrust with the kingship it's gonna do
a lot of damage to reveal that info so
yeah I get like I get how it could have
been a stronger choice to just confront
it right away and I've been watching all
this stuff that does that yeah at the
same time I get why you might not have
just gung-ho revealed that info and also
what good is it gonna do to a guy who is
clearly held in in terms of the people
the council were saying he has a right
to challenge the chala because he is the
son of the challahs uncle there's
certain facts that I think would have
swated people to go no he
shouldn't have a right and no one even
bothers to question like where did this
kid come from because he wasn't born in
Wakanda you know no one bothers to ask
these questions this kid was born in
America outside of Wakanda though that
one I can see why itit Allah chose not
to bring it up and to let the secret
just remain the other thing though that
I really do think could have been
brought up kill monger has a specific
line he says I was able to do the thing
you're a king couldn't do which is bring
a call T'Challa knows that they had claw
in their possession they were ready to
bring claw back but kill mongers the one
who broke claw now didn't account for
you yeah kill monger broke him out
brought him to Wakanda when they were
gonna just do that already so they
sabotage the mission that they were
already about to fulfill but yeah kill
mongers getting all the credit for
bringing claw in yeah that's a very you
could have saved at least some face by
being like yo yo we did the mission just
things went pear-shaped yeah cuz I
always kind of get an upset for on
characters behaves when they're like no
no no I I did it you're just upset at me
because I didn't complete it or do it
right and that was one of the things was
like if you talked to Daniel who use
character I feel like you could have
explained that exactly because Daniel
kahlúa and and we got it man it's yeah
it went wrong went wrong and it's
because of this guy that it went wrong
yeah and then Daniel Cole probably
wouldn't have sided with kill mom that
is heartbreaking although thinking of it
in that regard you're like oh we could
have saved ourselves I mean regardless
of that I mean you could you can call it
a nitpick ruin the whole moon no it's
nothing ruin the movie because the film
is still fantastic it's still great and
it's still filled with a bunch of
amazing little moments yeah I love the
way everything plays out in a setup like
I keep saying structure in the early
part of this movie when T'Challa is
ready to become king of Wakanda mbaku
challenges him to a fight I remember the
first time I watch it it was intense it
was cool but I was also thinking this is
probably all the time we're gonna see
this guy probably not gonna come back
it's just here to set up or so he can
become king just a big tough guy with
some personality cuz there's no
character goes wasted in here that first
fight has two great effects first thing
is when he fights Michael B Jordan when
he fights kill monger that makes that
fight so much more intense and so much
more heartbreaking and that
immediately elevate skill monger status
being a threat you've seen it once and
it yes a huge dude like a dude who
T'Challa probably has to work to take
yeah exactly physicality so the fact
that he beat T'Challa make skill monger
that much scarier and even though I of
course it's a Black Panther movie it's a
Marvel movie I wasn't there going oh
hopefully good this whole is actually
dead but I still feel the weight of what
the characters are going through yeah
that's the best thing that can be done
for an all's lost moment in movies like
this is at least feeling the gravity of
the situation I know black man who's
gonna come back to the save the day the
important thing is you feel the weight
in that dark night of the soul well yeah
they use that for more than just oh who
is he dead is he dead it's not just an
audience trick it's also you get to
spend some time with some other
characters seeing effects seeing the
context and you get you know certain
subplots unfold due to that yeah see I
thought they really used it even though
you of course - Chavez get a good back
when Sheree
Nakia and Ramon de two challahs mom all
go and Everett Ruess go every mbaku to
give him the the Black Panther flowers
so that way he can have the powers of
the black panther that was a great scene
that's the choice to let T'Challa have
the flower be able to regain the Black
Panther powers was a great choice and
well justified when he says a life for a
life you saved my life and now I'll save
your life you know it's just doing
what's right yeah and there's respect
there you can tell that even though
there's friction when they go to visit
him there is there is still tension but
he seems like a good lead like that just
comes through in that cuz the second
time watching this I realize how
well-written mbaku also was because when
he first shows up onto the scene he's
immediately pointed out Shuri saying
you're letting this country's technology
evolve offered this little girl who has
no respect for tradition which
immediately sets up the character to say
two challahs life because he respects
tradition you know they don't agree he
respect he has a level of respect and it
would kill mongers whole storyline I
love everything they did with Michael B
Jordan in this film the threat level yet
increasing when he burns all those
flowers you're like yeah that's that's
one of the most beautiful things
especially you know everyone talks about
marvel
problem I thought like the execution of
kill monger throughout the movie is
beautiful because you ramp up slowly and
then yeah what he's really taking over
and doing irreparable changes to what
Conda itself the stakes are huge like
you that scene where he's in the burning
room he just turns back around you see
all that dark it's not just cool yeah
the marble body shot he's consuming
there's also cool visual telling shots
when after the flowers of birthday is
walking into the council the cameras
upside down and turning over yeah yeah
you know that scene when T'Challa and
kill monger fight one of my favorite
moments just a little tiny moment in
here when Zuri is the one taking out you
know removing the Black Panther powers
as a Chawla and he has this little
moment where he walks past kill monger
and makes eye to eye with him looks at
him and you see this sense of guilt and
this responsibility so when he saves the
challahs life and makes sense because it
was foreshadowed in that one moment lose
little details like that that I really
appreciated man this movie has such a
great effect with the kill monger guy I
see why he's the main thing people are
talking about because when they're
fighting like by the train or whatever
it's a great fight Black Panther beats
him but then like a second later come
hungers this like that's a good move man
yeah I respect the battle and respects a
solid warrior and he starts to tear up
he because he's like my father told me
about what Conner says the most
beautiful place ever right in that
moment I started tearing up for they I'm
like one second I'm like beat him Black
Panther the next second Oh kill me you
see what went wrong you're like a
lifetime of others that unfair life II
grew up yeah that led to so much
violence and so much killing and it's
like it's too late but you catch that
glimpse of what it could have been
easily the most powerful line I think in
the whole movie and I wish I remembered
it word for word
right before I kill monger takes the
blade out of his heart he's talking
about how he wouldn't want to be a
prisoner that he wants to just assume
like his ancestors and throw him out
into the ocean cuz it's better to be
free than in Chains yeah and that line
is so damn powerful because this movie
has such cool respect for
the African culture and whole because it
does more than just say black people
have had a tough life and which is
absolutely true it is important to be
acknowledged because it does touch on
that subject but it also does a lot of
showing the love of African culture as
well when you're just exploring wakana
in the city I mean I know what Kahn is
fictional but there's a lot that pays
tribute and is in tune with how Africa
based on a real country inspired by real
places and I really loved with kill
monger that they Joe full-bore with his
becoming the King and all that and he
gets to go to the spirit realm and he
talks again to his father from yeah like
I thought that scene was really
beautiful never go straight to it just
took it to places I never expected them
to go you get his philosophies all
around the use of Everett Ross in this
film I rewatched Civil War again before
watching this one watching a civil war
every time I watch that film I go man
Martin Freeman is really wasted in this
movie he just say cliche lines at the
CIA guy would say yeah I felt the same
way actually I was like really I was so
excited to see you hear what and in this
movie he really gets a chance to shine
he gets a chance to be a hero that scene
when he is shooting down the plains and
then there's one point shooting animus
is real like o of the hologram and then
he's able to see that he's gonna die
soon he makes the choice because he's
thinking I could sacrifice my own life
right now if I could just take down this
one plane yeah because that this one
plane gets out there the world is
screwed and it's cool because the movie
doesn't feel about saving the world yet
that's ever at Ross's motivation in that
moment so they manage to make saving the
world a very personal motivation and not
the nebulous idea of like oh we have to
stop the world from bad guys it's like
the weight of people's choices and yeah
what the effect like the effects of
those choices happen to be ignoring yeah
you know and he's really funny in the
film too I was surprised by like how how
humorous his character was handled yeah
and it went from just being like oh cool
they cast you to be like they really let
you shine and they also gave your
character elements that are that are
really cool and really healthy yeah
Okoye yay all right how'd you say any
mikonos forget Danai gurira Danai gurira
watching this one the second time it
just really hit me how powerful our
character is because oh you got
two characters here you got several
female characters but there's two
characters that play a good comparison
contrast with each other her character
and the pizza nyan goes character
Nakia Nakia is a girl who doesn't really
agree with the way what Condor runs
things she wants she thinks we should be
helping the world and she doesn't really
feel like she belongs where as Guerrera
just feels like no this is what she's
meant to do because after touch Allah
dies it was a powerful scene where a koi
a saying I have to stay I mean even
though kill mongers King I have this is
what I'm supposed this is you like this
is what I stand for for Wakanda and the
pizza aggregates confronted for the of
the question of where do I belong and
she doesn't have an answer for that you
just know she they have to take down
kill monger them no matter what well
they're both like different shades of
tough wood yeah nice they're both
totally dimensional characters and I
liked this movie as a through-line kind
of has that quality of you get different
pairs of characters with similar
determinations but very different
philosophy yeah I mean those two
characters are all both just want to do
the right thing yeah they're both
fighters they're both fighters they both
want to do the right thing and what's
interesting about both of their arcs
they kind of evolve into each other in a
surgery where they come to Seymour I tie
and couldn't approach in a similar way
cuz Akoya is arc I really felt it when
she decides when she goes you are not
fit to be king to kill monger when she
goes this isn't right yeah you know I've
been just going I'm one of a kind of so
I have to follow you but this isn't
right I can't just do my job and follow
my orders anymore which is what Nakia
would have done a long time ago but also
Nakia evolves into becoming a warrior
she even wears the outfit when she's
fighting in the finale and then she
stands by side with life and so she then
she becomes someone who's a part of
Wakanda again yeah they both kind of
evolve into these roles it was just
interesting to watch them kind of switch
and there's so many things happening
while the main story progresses so many
characters developing and coming into
different statuses within the story and
there's just a credit to everything to
the writing the directing the
performance is overall Sheree two
challahs sister yeah amazing in this
film I I cannot get over that technology
scene when she is showing like when he
has the sandal
and then he's go he goes what are these
and she goes one bigger question is
water
she loves Wakanda and she understands
his technology better than anyone but
she has such a loose modern-day free
spirit about herself and T'Challa and
heard her chemistry together is just so
fantastic well that was fun because it
put humour in places I wasn't expecting
it to go like that joke specifically
came and I was like I wasn't expecting
either sometimes you can tell when they
are gonna lighten up a moment or Mia
make it crack the moments of humor I
thought were always kind of expertly
snuck in there yeah and I guess the last
things to touch on you pretty much
written the whole movie touch on in this
it's a rich film yeah I'm always
thinking with the things that I felt
truly powerful about the ending of this
film is amazing because to telezart in
this film he starts off and he just
wants to be the right king and follow in
his father's footsteps even in the
beginning he's talking to his father in
the afterlife and he's telling his dad
that he's not ready to let him go in the
end of the film
a little bit before the finale he
confronts his dad again in his tells him
he's wrong and that he wants to run
things differently I remember thinking
it's kind of fascinating that we're
focusing specifically on T'Challa this
King when there's been numerous Kings by
now but we're choosing to focus on this
one it's because he's gonna change the
path of Wakanda yeah and that's what the
movie really becomes about it's not a
black panther origin necessarily or a
story about a guy becoming a king it's
about what kind of king what kind of
warrior are you gonna be he has even has
a line to kill Munger where he says I'm
not king of the world I'm king of
Wakanda because he's all about
protecting Wakanda and keeping a secret
so that ending when he decides to build
some type of foundation where they can
do technological open up to the world
finally and the fact that they're using
the building where his uncle died is so
powerful because they're giving that
building a different definition and
they're doing in the ghetto and helping
out you know the poorer rural parts of
like an African American culture in
California one thing I love when people
treat what-if scenarios as realistic as
possible this movie's established that
there's this world here where Africans
have been treated terrible and then
there's this part of Africa secret part
where there's
kondou where everything's better than
the rest of the world reverse of what
you have a Africa and be really the
whole world the whole world and they've
kind of been holding out on the rest of
humanity right now you get you get why
so there's a mid-credits scene that I
thought was really effective he's
talking to the public and he's telling
people that they're gonna start sharing
the technological advancements and they
have no idea what's in store which can
be huge for the MCU
this can change almost everything for
the MCU it's bigger than I am Iron Man
Everett Ross gets shot in the spine
they're able to like subdue the pain for
a while and heal him within a day now I
can just only imagine what rest of the
technology they have it's more than just
spaceships and cool guns you know
characters ever have to die exactly no
stakes that also leads into infinity war
because as you see in in the infinity
war trailer they start attacking Wakanda
and now that what conda's mean reveal to
the public that leaves the door open for
bad guys you should've killed this roll
out maybe a few movies this will
probably be how Captain America gets a
new shield because you're gonna plug in
a bill a mohawk on I think they is in
the infinity war trailer actually
exactly that ending is great because it
still contained in the personal effect
of what Conda being willing to share
with the world and help the rest of the
world out then it didn't dawn on me talk
for the second viewing like wait a
minute this could change how the rest of
the MCU films play out now oh yeah yeah
it's gonna definitely expand things out
in all kinds of ways and all kinds of
capabilities I'm really curious to see
what that does to things because they
have some pretty amazing tech the Marvel
Cinematic Universe only gets more
advanced and crazy and intricate so I
really wonder what the future what phase
for let's say is gonna look like based
on all this because there's a lot of
really fantastical stuff in the Marvel
Universe now all in all this movie is
just an amazing film I think it's easily
one of Marvel's top three best fold it
man I would say it's probably their
richest film for sure but I think is
cool about this I just did a video that
we put up on the channel about how I
want comp of movies to evolve and one of
the main points I touch on is building
universes within the grander scheme of
the universe and to me I feel like this
is a good start
point four black panther because I'm not
really aware of the rest of the MCU when
I'm watching this film and that was a
nice thing to just be in this universe
and I have a couple things yeah I'm
around yeah because it feels like they
built a universe a black panther or
universe and I hope that for the future
installments they continue to do that
and that's what kind of what the comics
are like truthfully is every solo series
has its own vibe has its own experiences
world yeah and then when they get
together it's got its own tambien again
yeah it's not just about the grander one
it's about crossing universes amongst
each other so I hope Black Panther the
franchise continues on this path of
building its own universe and not so
much about making a bunch of tie-ins to
the other parts of the MCU they don't
need to and you know what man this film
is great and I hope that people remember
this by the end of the year in terms of
like Oscar season because I think it I
think it's Oscar worthy in certain
departments I think there's certain
things that are definitely hospital yeah
it definitely elevates its genre for
sure I would love to see it recognized
for at least something it may be an
ensemble award at one of the acting
awards SAG Awards yeah yeah yeah I can
see that definitely a visual effects
yeah oh yeah yeah it looks amazing
alright guys well what are some things
specifics now's your time hasn't ruined
the movie for everyone in the comment
boxes put it in the comment box below at
your favorite parts of the movie are
things you wish we touched on that
you're pissed about that we did not talk
about subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification well you get
notified every time one of our videos is
up and check out our patreon a lot of
exclusive videos on their weekly Q&A is
full-length TV show music video
reactions at a bunch of other posts as
well cuz I'll see you guys